when you go on a show like supergirl
right mm-hmm if you go on a show on
supergirl and you played supergirl
that's got to be a weird thing to say
okay i'm going to be a guest star on a
show called supergirl when i was
supergirl in smallville
and then was that was that a fun
experience
yep it was yep
okay so we don't want to talk about this
we don't want to talk about this because
i talked to erica durants who was on
there and
you know um she said it was fine it was
fine
were the people nice some of them yeah
some of them were really nice yeah yeah
they do feel nice
yeah and some of them didn't some of
them didn't the the character was fun
i was blue and i was a villain and it
was very different i'm parlaying i'm
just like pivoting yeah you could be
pivoting you could do it you were blue
it was blue all right uh it's it's got
to be like i don't think i could do it
like for instance
there was a show called lex luthor and
then they said hey we want you to come
in to play a character
i don't know i don't know if i'd feel
i it depends my ego would say
ah there's only one there's only one
[ __ ] lex luthor
that's what my ego would say right if it
was a good enough role
maybe i would think differently but if i
got on set and i was people were acting
a little weird to me or something
and it's always different for guys guys
have a lot easier
women don't women it's not easy it's not
easy
always having to look great and always
having to be thin and always having to
you know it's all about your looks and
you know guys could grow a beard and
go oh i think i've got an audition
haven't you had four beers yeah no one
gives a [ __ ]
i hate shaving my beard but i have to do
it all the time i hate shaving my beard
i gotta do it every day